oh hey
and welcome to another halo 5 stream on
now playing
at gamespot.com i'm joined here with
mike mchardy
eric tay myself rob handlery we are
playing co-op
halo 5.
uh currently we're having a little
difficulties with today's xbox here
unfortunately
um but the good thing about halo 5 is
there is supposedly drop in dropout
cooperative play so we're going to kick
it off
on mission 8
and tay will hopefully uh drop in
that's the hope and the plan that's the
hope and the plan we'll see but anyways
let's get right to it
uh yeah so start a new machine starting
mission so we are in a fire team
um
on heroic here
uh
yeah so far fire teams are pretty great
i like
we were trying to play so multiplayer
was released today as well
um
for the pre-release copies and
unfortunately i think you got in a match
eric got a match i had some difficulties
for the arena mode warzone um there will
be some dedicated servers tomorrow and
through the weekend um you know
essentially you need uh 18
people
um on each team for war zone max in
order to start a game so we have to uh
it's just difficult there's not many
people playing is the issue okay anyways
uh do you want to be locked or you want
me to be locked uh you can be lost so at
least one person needs to be locked like
the squad leader if the team has to be
chief
so if i were to yeah we found this out
earlier is if i were to pick buck and
there's only two of us playing he
automatically has to be uh agent lock
yeah are you guys on the right mission
and they have different um no this is
the first yeah yeah we are we are it's
just saying fire team osiris because
uh
mission
hey
okay is this mission eight
so we're just saying helios is his
mission yeah oh we're good
sorry we kind of panicked we can only
show mission one to three and then
mission eight and this mission eight
later on there's
14 total but a couple of them are
well get into it later um
yeah each character has different
loadouts briefing for you by the time we
reach the hedge
so you wrote a target dossier on the
arbiter when you wrote tony
that was six years ago
what's your point
you recommended assassinating him
things changed
oh
damn
this all goes sideways i understand sir
it's not my first mission that doesn't
exist
shhh cool so we're pairing up some
elites so i believe there's a civil war
going on right with the the covenant and
then kind of like a
new age rebellion right it's the elites
versus this like splinter cell of the
old covenant that's kind of a terrorist
sect now okay and yeah we're going to
the elite home world which is pretty
cool saying helios nice
i guess the covenant calls elite sing
healy but
it's a pretty cool uh planet
a few missions on it
oh nice
phantom
this takes place on the day the game
releases
sweet
all right so each character has
different loadouts that they spawn with
um you see
buck who rob is playing as
as the assault rifle pistol
um
lock has the battle rifle snipe uh
pistol then
vale has
smg plasma pistol which is interesting
i guess the plasma pistol
she knows saying healy like they get
into it here at some point mm-hmm she
could speak it she's kind of connected
to the covenant in weird ways but um
you know then there's like a sniper
rifle shotgun on blue team this chief in
them okay but um
yeah it's kind of cool i guess you just
start off with better weapons than you
might normally i guess bucks is kind of
a normal uh loadout
got some classic sky boxes here in halo
i think we'll see some cooler stuff
later yeah yeah so yeah we um
you've been uh the campaign i've i've
played i got one mission left um but
these missions have been really cool
um a lot of like vertical gun play and
you know just like levels of like an
attack um more so like predominantly
like any other halo i played like you
can you can really climb and use the
terrain to your advantage yeah you get
to clamber over ledges you get the oh
[ __ ]
here we go so also
uh in halo
5 i've been noticing a lot of these
paths over here
so you you essentially use this oh let
me try that again you use a spartan um
charge
and you can get through um
you know sneak around sometimes i find i
found skulls i found weapons carbine so
this is clutch ooh whoops i what'd you
do i did the ground pound and killed him
but then i got shots ground pound is
addicting
hopefully they'll get me that tanaka's
got me
so yeah with four player cops a little
better you don't have to really rely on
the ai
where are you at i'm good the ai kind of
ranges from really good to just really
dumb
sure
i'd say like yeah the
ai is
can be very weak
but you do
see a lot more
diversity in how you how you attack like
uh we'll see not maybe not in this level
because i don't think there's the the
prometheans are the other aliens that
you fight and i think they're in this
level
but you know certain ones hunters
hunters you obviously want to get around
um
and shoot their weak point in the back
but uh yeah just in general um a lot of
diversity and like tactics and how you
attack enemies then uh if you're this
the leader like master chief or lock you
can tell people to attack certain
enemies like that turret was kind of i
guess more of a threat
so you can kind of tell them hey shoot
that you can also tell them to pick up
specific weapons for the ai and use
certain vehicles which if you're playing
by yourself it's a really helpful hot
[ __ ] yeah
um you know if you don't want to pick up
the rocket launcher but you want someone
else to
use it because the ai is actually decent
with like power weapons
nice and so you are locked so you are
still the commanding officer of the unit
so um
because we have two other ais someone
needs to kind of give them commands or
the ability to command i can't do
anything so i've up on the d-pad should
be like tell people what to do if i was
playing this lock all i have is a ping
that can kind of like you know show me
what's up
oh missed [ __ ]
so you want sometimes you want to like
replay these levels because look at over
here i found an intel
right
like
so there's intel scattered around the
map
uh here's one right here
where the hell are you josh wants to cut
to it right here so i found this
oh i see
yeah so there's let's see how many there
are there eight
twelve
there's twelve
uh throughout this map
i think it is oh i must've already
gotten that one or just gave it to me
too for you finding it oh really
okay let's uh there's uh
where you're at oh is that leaning up
against the
look i thought that was a cloaked elite
nevermind oh that's a sword right yeah
it looks like a cloaked elite holding it
but it's just leaning up against the
wall
one of us are probably a
star rifle you know i've never been a
huge fan of the sword it's fun but like
it's just it's equivalent to like a
shotgun but worse like you have to be
really close i need to get
i'll use it oh there's an intel up here
also let's see if it gives it to you
yeah yep okay cool
and you already got it looks like so
we'll go with that careful lots of cover
ahead snipers on that ridge
oh
what was that
snipe
oh uh pick me up yeah it was a sniper
uh
oh jeez i see one up there
got him he's dead
i'm gonna try something there's probably
still snipers left i would imagine i
don't know where oh that was tight
yeah the hovers i've been using that a
lot more often it's pretty useful oh
drop odds heads up
oh
damn
there's a guy that turret
all right here we go
oh [ __ ] he's dead
i was about to ground pound the guy you
killed or someone killed
nice
pistol's still a great weapon well maybe
not oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh there's a beam rifle here i can use
this
oh [ __ ] ramp on the right he says
look there's like all these passages
yeah here's like another one there's an
elite up on the ledge up there
oh
i like oh my god that was so good i
opened up this door this like passageway
and there's an elite just hanging out
there yeah there it is oh here we go oh
do it
kill good [ __ ] i want to keep that um
uh did someone get you someone giving to
you no [ __ ]
i have no idea how you got up there no
not really oh i see it
whip
yeah you can let's do it
what is up here
oh
plasma caster so is this a new weapon
yeah it is straight up like it wasn't in
four i i feel like i've seen it before
but it's like a plasma grenade launcher
but the grenades you can charge it up to
do more damage but the grenades do
damage over time so it's kind of a burn
effect instead of just one explosion
yeah
um they kind of rain down so yeah it's
like a um i don't know it's like there's
a lot of splash damage
so yeah as you can see these missions
are a little more open
a few different
routes you can take and different angles
to attack from i guess yeah now you're
definitely doing
a lot more exploring more so than any
other halo game i've ever played you
know yeah i'm done
give me like two seconds
all right let's try this caster out oh
you're up anders oh there he is
oh yeah you got him
that was a nice kill buck
thanks
alright try this again explode there we
go
um
two for two here
there's a phantom shooting for little
that plasma castle looks huge on your
back
oh yeah see what's through here go for
it
um just a different that's what's cool
you know like getting above that you
move around i'll keep them distracted
like the pathways are eventually
definitely using myself up here
like four player would be really fun you
know i have two guys go up through there
oh damn it there's a club to leave with
a sword where i just died
tanaka's probably gonna get down right
now
i shouldn't have called for assistance
actually oh yeah oh they're they're all
going for you
um yeah he's right next we're all down
he's right next to us
so i will respond as you can see in like
15 seconds
he's well he
[ __ ] he's right there
nice shot you got him
he's not dead but his shield now
nice jerk
so now i'm back but we have to wait for
a checkpoint for them to respond hey i
don't respond to a checkpoint from what
i understand oh okay
or maybe that's the same thing they do
the same thing as humans they just
uh come back after like 20 seconds or so
oh no
oh no
sniper down there okay come back thanks
they're way up here tearing and sneak
behind
oh there's a beam rifle right here we go
got some sniper there oh yeah they're
back
oh oh you killed him
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm sorry
what the heck
you're damn right there's friendly fire
i mean i knew there's friendly fire but
i didn't realize you were like would you
did you throw something no i did a
spartan smash and then or a ground pound
right after you killed him i guess in
the air charging it
yeah
well that was my fault
i think it's clearly my fault i don't
know why i need to clarify that but
i'm out of ammo for this i'm gonna try
to get
something better
oh [ __ ] don't get on that don't get on
that
all right let's try another ground down
here where are you at oh
[ __ ] there's another guy with a plasma
sword over next to me
or and a fuel rod cannon sweet so you
know what's like interesting is like as
you know like swords
like a lot of times an elite will right
behind him has got the sword
what am i doing to knock out let's go
quick
what am i doing
oh i died immediately
what killed you a fuel rod
uh yeah
no we're not sorry
all right i'm gonna get rid of i don't
know how useful this sword is right now
but so were there draw pods that came in
well moves on yeah there's a few elites
one's got an energy sword one's gotta
well they switch weapons now the energy
the ones with the energy can put them
all the way yeah that's what i want to
say before i canadian died they uh
they'll
they used to just take out oh my god
they should just take out a sword
and
always have it and then until you kill
them but now they i've seen him put
swords away which is really interesting
uh it makes it more difficult
because that was the part he's like you
know if he pulls out a sword and he's
really far away you can just
hose him down oh damn it just fell down
a very deep ravine
yeah where are you going i don't know
there we go go this way
um
how do i get up there
where did you go i don't know i fell
down
here but we gotta go back up right now
i'm stuck with you god
you just go we just go uh
oh my
god don't know
shooting me
it's got dropped down too
um we're getting up there maybe yeah
it's this way
i think you're going away yeah
here we go
make that jump
when you go around
dude
no man we came and we're so lost we came
in it's actually this way remember this
we went up this way this is totally it
okay
yeah
just a pretty open-ended map i guess
normally i would not fall down that
canyon yeah that's it but
it happens
it does happen
you live you live you learn
oh yeah then i went through here all
right let me go back up here again
all right
game rifle back okay so they're still
around here somewhere
oh no
nice
wow
i have four percent of this storm right
here to get rid of this
put this off
that was a fuel rod
cool
of course you can do this stuff too take
off the turret
there's some new like
uh promethean turrets that are pretty
tight yeah they're like these little
rockets right they're really uh nasty
the hovering is great yeah the hot ring
is really great
i mean that's what i really like about
these abilities that they're not i don't
know they're not so gimmicky like so
many games have been doing lately
just throwing in movement they're like
each
each of the movements they throw in
just feel
necessarily
yeah uh
put like they they just work like hovers
the dash is useful on higher
difficulties just to get around corners
quick especially in multiplayer actually
when you're someone shooting you're
about to drain your shield just kind of
dash out of the way
um i think we're going we're going back
up here where we cleared out right
yeah so this map is really cool you got
all these like awesome statues of elise
swords and stuff
some of the interiors have been really
great as well
these are pre-covered
they were already ancient history before
humanity
cool planet cool planet good looking
game
yeah really great looking game
it's weird there's a beast it's like
almost desertish right next to an ocean
it's more like just cliffs not exactly
desert there's a temple over there where
they just i guess the arbiter's over
there oh [ __ ] there's uh something
underneath here we can bust through cool
i'm gonna go on top all right i'll go
down
are they both with you oh no tanaka's
following me val's following you oh nice
two and two oh there's a lot of
oh i fell down
didn't see that crack
all right let this thing rip
grenade heads up
[ __ ]
well that was pretty useful i kind of
used the hover when i was
trying to jump away from a grenade but
then i still could shoot him while i was
dodging
oh so look at this we got like a yeah
there's a bunch of different ways to
take those out um yeah so there's a
thing behind there's a wall right here
next to it
oh nice all right now i'm through i can
blow that up
and there are plasma casters here if you
want one oh hunters
oh my god i'm like i'm getting that
plasma faster
they just smoke the
veil i don't know they'll still up
miss the days in the pistol just one
shot in the back and be done with it
yeah there's like another passage here
oh [ __ ] there's the other one
should have used dash i'm down
here
if you can get me
are you down yeah
might be tough with hunters that 100 is
almost dead the armor's gone from his
back
hey guys
yeah i keep i still have to get the dash
muscle memory kind of
all right
be a little smarter about that cool kind
of oh good i wanted to kind of stay up
on top anyway
damn it oh my gosh
all right
kind of rush kind of rushed in there oh
she can get me maybe
nope
all right
just about to get up yeah those snipers
oh she messed me up
she's spazzing out yeah she's kind of
surprising all right let's
figure this out yeah
sniper up there i'm gonna kill that
thing
oh hello
oh man
oh come on i just got stuck dude this
guy this guy randomly no it's not gonna
don't run up she's got stuck too someone
has a plasma caster that keeps killing
us that's stuck this is funny all right
well
great
i feel like we were fine the first time
i thought so too
all right let's kill this elite
oh my god wrong
oh check this out
what's up
nice
shot veil in the face all right
all right i'm gonna have to get off when
these hunters come yeah i'm also gonna
go try to get that plasma caster
all right it should be good yep
no thanks
okay
yeah like all the sound effects and the
weapon designs like when you when you
aim down sights they just they're so
well done yeah the sound effects on
that right i'm behind this dude should
be able to stick him i don't know i got
him though
go
just kind of run around oh here we go
so the hunters if you shoot them from
the front they will sometimes bat away
your grenades and right here watch this
it's pretty cool let's see if they do it
yeah he did he bounced it right away oh
oh god i think
i think he tried to bounce it maybe got
stuck on him i don't know
yeah there we go
so there was a shield here did you pop
that open was there anything in the past
it was the plasma casters okay
there's a little rock wall next to it
you can blow up some sweets
all right uh-oh i do like the way she
thinks i'm gonna get up higher because i
feel like very loud
tight all right well uh
why not
some of the swords too helpful here i'm
gonna go with the caster
uh how many are those oh sweet or two
right so if you were playing with four
people uh you know two in the mantises
and then i believe
right around the corner there is a
wraith tank
oh yeah watch out for that
things are so fun in multiplayer
let's do this to someone i'm gonna try
not to destroy this wraith i'm gonna
have the other two get in there as
possible second uh this wraith right
here i usually destroy them so oh yeah
but uh i'm gonna get in it okay let me
change it up i don't know should i
um
ah
i'll get in the race you use the mantis
okay oh you and can you tell um i can
you tell someone else to use a wraith
yeah or the mantis
mantis right
cool
so tanaka's in the mantis hopefully she
oh yeah she uses it i think she
automatically does it yeah got a veil on
the turret oh yeah freaking race
boom got it oh no barely
did the did the man sis always have a
cool down on the machine gun
i think
so i don't remember that
but
i don't remember this is still pretty
new it only was introduced in halo 4.
all right that wraith is down
as you might have noticed
oh she's stomping she's just not that
guy i'm gonna go down here on the right
you can go on top of tanaka's over here
as well
oh watch this
oh what
oh hundreds down below hello all right
the hunters have like an auto
uh i'm running right now you can just we
can distract them for each other
yeah one's down
i told him to target the left oh dude
he's
you have a melee too yeah oh yeah but
it's damn right i do it's
it's uh i don't know i haven't been in
the right situation yeah you're not
you're not trying to use it as much as
you are just like
given the opportunity uh we just jumped
over there
missed him
let's do it
oh there's someone in here
i want to get in there are the ghosts
here
oh yeah
you're done
nice tanaka's
doing some stuff for us
in this mentos
man the wreath is so different than it
used to be
yeah it used to have a dash like left
and right i believe or just maybe it was
a dash it was just a faster one now it
does but it's more of a
yeah it's like a ghost
sprint yeah
so
you're dead oh there's a turret i don't
know if you can see it i think you're on
the right of it i should be able to get
it nevermind
manchester's kind of falling apart here
turrets down
elite with a look at this elite uh he
just did like 17 barrel rolls that's
right
love his turret
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] something
it just hit me someone just sent me the
plasma oh there's a race there you say
that yes yeah
got some i'm above them
you really gotta argue these rape
cannons yeah
he's almost done yeah
so there's a there's a shield there's
like a hidden passage i want to try to
get into
like how would i oh wait oh there's an
open door how did it open up that's
weird
okay hold on i want to look in here and
see what happens i'm just going to start
launching stuff in there
okay ghost
is tanaka still intact yeah yeah she is
sweet
all in all that went pretty well just a
ghost for how like close quarters that
was for vehicle combat drive sword ghost
what is the difference between that and
an actual ghost
a sword ghost it's called a sword it
might be the swords of like saying
helios that's the art okay oh yeah
you're right that's it
that'd be awesome if you could like yeah
right spider people with the swords that
would be cool jousting
oh this elites dodging everything
all right um
i might have you go in first because the
rate is kind of okay i agree
yeah going first should be fine
oh this is where when i played
uh i i did this respawn so many times
because my mantis was just destroyed so
any small hit just going through this
ambush on me area
can you make it up this ramp to the
right
yeah i think so yeah yeah
yeah come on come on
we made it
[ __ ] hello where's i think i'm blocking
tanaka from getting in there so i'm
going to kind of move a little bit
bad idea all right see that's doing a
decent job clearing out the grunts
around me i'm just going to start
launching [ __ ] over there
oh
clever
oh god there's more and he's got a fuel
rod oh
there's two elites with fuel rods i
marked him
can you see what i'm marking i didn't i
can't see he's right there [ __ ]
damn it
okay i think we're good
good ish
i'm gonna splatter this ground
he's already dead oh i've just found
something right here
okay so i think these are all
allies
um okay i'm getting out of here now
and thanks for blocking it off i'll back
it up
god you're such a jerk
i should be able to go in there too i'm
going to launch a few things in there
first i'm riding this to death
bragging
come on
gonna go on foot
yeah
oh is that an ally oh god damn it i'm
sure
yeah we're almost there though probably
on the mission oh these are all allies
what am i doing
is that it that's it
kill him
hit him in the net
so
yeah that's the last of that mission we
can show cool
can go back to an earlier one yeah let's
do um let's do mission three
is one of my favorites and it looks like
we got i don't know we'll see
it
it is possible
that we'll have a third
i got high hopes
yeah eric is shaping the office are busy
but hopefully we'll get to four player
at some point today not on stream um
should we cut from this
um i'm not positive so i'm going to yes
yeah cut from this so
see ya
yeah
uh so yeah we can do it earlier mission
one two or three
cool uh three was great no
no two let's do two yeah okay place
chief okay
blue team
uh
yes seems good
yes
all right
and
start
should we wait no you guys should we're
gonna start we can see if we can drop
someone in sorry we'll start it we'll
start it
cool so this is the second mission this
is actually one of my favorite missions
it's pretty long for it's long and it's
dope
and there's a lot of
different areas and elevations a lot of
elevations
uh
it's fun
let's watch this sweet
cinematic
pelicans are so badass
yeah they're the coolest things ever
i sent you my position three weeks ago i
told you this was happening discuss that
in private doctor
what have she done how far has it
already gone
good work osiris
what do you think that's about
it's a cutscene kind of under the weird
spot you want to be leader
uh or you want to be who are you okay
i'll be chief okay uh we'll see what
they start with linda's a sniper kelly's
shotgun fred's
oh it's so sh okay can you customize
that at all i mean if it gets an extra
frag grenade is armor's equipped with
faster shield regeneration kelly
movement speed fast shield and health
generation and then linda
what's master chief are you getting
selected or what i'll be i'll be a
sniper oh i'm looking at mass chief
motion tracker range and quick shield
another generation cool
chief
did it say yeah it said it was like look
like health and i think maybe speed i
don't know cool
if you forgot to look at uh
osiris's osiris they have their own like
new tech and stuff that kind of helps
them
blue teams more just
the fact that they're
super humans
they look really cool too she pressed
himself like this since we were in boot
camp he's fine fred this many missions
non-stop isn't fun
sierra 117 to infinity blue team is
located argent moon signs of hostile
activity but she's still here
mommy
thanks kelly
everyone ready
just get out of my way
fall out
whoa
throw who out the airlock what do you
say
throw some out the airlock
hey
later
god they look so stupid just there
all right spawn with the sniper rifle
let's see how this guy looks great oh
look at that
there's like a light yeah all the
weapons are so cool looking is that
paint yeah it's like paint
a little camo on the side there
yeah it's awesome she's just cool hurt
her you're hot your house you're hot
dude cool in general oh wait look you're
hot see both scopes oh is that like the
return oh that's you double mags you
have two sites right yeah yeah oh
actually no no no the one on the right
is this like infrared one
linda's got her sorry yeah
kelly's got her shotgun she's also
faster when she sprints
which is pretty cool
let's race
let's race dude
prove it
yeah prove it
uh no kelly is but we could try oh
all right let's let's go all right wait
well i will get a little account here
what is this let's get further back
right here to the edge
all the way to the edge of here and we
race to the window hey fred we're busy
get out of the way
all right
don't touch him oh no okay
all right one two three
slide
all right well that was dumb all right
uh no no uh kelly's fastest oh that's
what you're saying i'm sorry kelly she's
uh okay according to halo laura she's
like the fastest one fred's the like
oh yeah the strongest one she's a
sprinter linda's always just like an odd
personality in the books because but
she's like a loner but well not a loner
but you know the typical sniper
personality just living in the woods
eating your ears when you run out of
food right
which a real person actually did in like
vietnam or something eating his ear like
cut off his ears he started eating parts
like his nose and ears cartilage because
dude they weren't necessary for his face
yeah because he was tracking this one
target for like two weeks or something
oh just sitting in one spot that's
horrifying that's warping all right so
yeah this mission also has you know
intel and such yeah um
they tend to be themed like these are
like stations
uh
yeah sometimes they're little
holograms
recording
don't breathe
so they're like each of the intel the
intel on each mission kind of goes into
this
tangent like different backstory than
like serves the main plot which is cool
i'm gonna spar and smash this no i've
got a ground pound
this way
yeah so
kelly's uh motion tracker has longer
range than everybody else
um
oh really
pretty useful it'd be more useful in
multiplayer but whoa dude
have you ever been down here i don't
think so maybe shotguns or something
there's shotguns littered all over this
ship
damn
i don't know there's a bunch of dead
bodies so i was you know
i'm just stick with a sniper
yeah there's shotguns everywhere in this
get these dudes quick lee
don't see them
ah all right let me
you got him uh there's one did you kill
that other elite
i shot at him nope
come here yeah oh wait here we go here
we go here we go i got a little too
aggressive oh there i am
oh you're dead yeah making sure you're
all right i'll give you a second he's
got you that's right so i'm uh i'm chief
i can command
the ai
take
oh he's running away no he's not
a waste of a sniper bullet but all right
oh i'm out of ammo
go then needler
data center there's a sword here if you
want it let's go data center
yeah so the needlers
when you aim down the size of the needle
and you smell like it puts up this
hologram on the side of it which is
pretty cool
i like how it's not just you know aiming
straight down the sites not that it has
sites the sites like are the
deadly part
uh so we gotta press the switch down
here i think yeah
cool site over here
you opened it
good eye good eye good eye
all right
all right let's press everyone in but
watch your fingers
because i lost i lost my my fourth
thinking that's always the body part i
worry about the elevators
your fingers yeah
there's a video the other day if someone
got on an elevator but the dog didn't so
the leash started pulling the dog up oh
my god but someone someone caught and
unhooked it and saved the dog oh my god
you should probably pay attention to
where your dog's walking if you're
getting out of the elevator oh dude
it was scary for a few seconds and the
guy saved it so okay cool
this video was worth watching i don't
want to see a dog get hurt
all right here we go
shotgun here if you need ammo
a lot of shotguns here
yeah i want to look around more always
like
oh [ __ ] sorry i forgot that's the
room you fall down into wouldn't have
gone for anyone oh
snipe a few smg i'll take it elites
while i'm here
oh [ __ ] so d scoping is
i think i got him
ah
elite right next to them
ah
oh geez
what's up
i just punched a wall
god this gun sounds so sick yeah this
smg sounds so much cooler than used to
and halo 2 when i first introduced
something like a
some weird like a stapler
a very fast stapler yeah
oh is that a fuel rod then
all right let's look for oh look josh is
doing split screen something that's
totally not possible with halo 5.
all right this guy's being a jerk
let's kill him now that'd be nice he's
dead okay
all right oh you want this no you go for
it so this is a new weapon that rob's
about to pick up yeah this is a new one
it's like a hydraulic launcher yeah it's
like a lock-on grenade launcher right
like it's it's a
yeah they're like missiles kind of weak
missiles but yeah help nonetheless i'm
gonna take your uh this dmr here if you
don't want it oh you can take it no
that's your gun you go for it it's right
out there's a shotgun yeah i will take
the shotgun
oh almost fall down
so this part is pretty huge room
um also oh my god that was so tight
what'd you do i locked onto a guy and he
like tried to fly back and the missile
followed him and killed him yeah this is
a good ground point if i could pull this
off here we go here we go
there's a lot of it's a bad uh
there we go
we're good
so i charged up my ground pound all the
way there's like 16 people there i got
two of four or three of them yeah
but yeah if you want to get the most
powerful it takes
some commitment and some time oh there's
snipers up there
i don't know if you can mark them
that's right i keep forgetting i'm i i
have guys i can tell people all right i
don't have the best long-range weapons
right now
i'll get in there
there's something through here
yeah okay i'll go with the smg here we
go
all right
here we go here we go this is it
i got him okay what ah there's like
go back run
oh that is embarrassing hurry up uh
right down here oh this guy right here
all right well then he deserves a group
oh he's gone you just got packed out of
there
so i'm close to dying oh sorry fred's
right there
he just scanned me back to life
oh damn i have so many of these hydra
rockets
got a carbon up here so that's good it's
my favorite weapon
any halo game
oh there's a guy back i got him i'm
gonna i'm gonna smash him and then i'm
gonna shotgun prove it
and then melee him because that first
match is not that oh yeah i think he was
uh oh yeah higher up okay i'm gonna get
that yeah
oh yeah
where are we going
so yeah the suits are different before
we had lock and when you ping
it's an older model suit so it just kind
of gives you the waypoint opposed to a
nice flashy
scan the mark v mule near armor from
what i understand
oh god
oh my god
there's always a brother um yeah it's
pretty cool you can actually see
the worm hive mine kind of forming a
little bit
yeah those guys are awesome
dude i fell down with you what's up with
that
yeah where the hell did i go
i guess we'll find out
did you
times
well
so chief is
having an episode it would appear
turns out
an entire lifetime of just
killing people do that to you
yeah
aliens and people when you started
the domain is open
meridian is next
cortana
the reclamation is about to begin
i like that she calls him john instead
of chief
she's allowed
uh chief
sorry i blacked out there for a second
what happened
who
cortana
duh
didn't you guys see that
all right let's be dark
and yeah uh so we were talking in
multiplayer they have a flashlight on
the shotgun at all times so you kind of
have a little more forewarning when
you're sprinting at someone that has one
yeah oh man there's so many shotguns
yeah there's alright do you want i don't
know what this hydrating
um yeah i i'm gonna if you don't want it
i'll take it just because there's
certain enemy coming up take it all
right take it
i'll take it i only have like uh five
they'll help i'll get it
uh oh [ __ ] so yeah be careful in this
these corridors oh don't don't spoil it
uh so many different ways to go i'm
gonna go this way because
my
my senses are telling me to go oh no
this is back to where we were great well
i'm an idiot
it's always like his team's just
following me around like
yeah uh chief you're kind of uh freaking
cheap right
sure you're all right chief you want to
sit down for a second
how many fingers how many fingers my
holding i think i'm in the right
yeah in the right area
can i
ping nope
whoa i want to go in this dark room by
myself
oh yeah i think you could drop down the
bottoms up
the opposite
oh there's a few oh
oh they were sleeping oh they were
sleeping
uh that was the kelly you dare blame it
was it you don't even know
i had nothing to do with that uh-huh uh
there's a few
there's a few elites cloaking right now
and i have no ammo that so i'm gonna use
these on him just launch them wildly
[ __ ] ooh their guns look so cool at
night
oh dark it's not nighttime that's
everything's nice
oh
there he
right at the end when you're fully
revived damn all
meridian
meridians okay so that went well
get this the plasma pistol sounds great
in this game too
compared to the usual
pew pew kind of thing
all right
sweet so
let's go far oh
all right there's someone freaking out
all right get a better plasma crystal
hopefully
a lot more oh this is a cool part so you
can see the uh
hunter worms
could
oh [ __ ]
there's one
downstairs
i looked away the wrong time
so the dash is useful there it's just
100 yeah getting used to it
is that dmr are you strapping i dropped
it there's like two volts left now
all right
oh there's another grenade in there
heads up
oh fred nice job
just run right at it we've got a lot of
ground left to cover
we should keep moving down don't tell me
what to do
oh i'm a little den there that's cool
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
don't judge me guys all right
god there's so many of them
he's dead
i said he was dead long before i even
did that much damage to him
shot him like three times the kneeler
assume that would be enough yeah
it wasn't was not
bottoms up
here we go
oh lame i can't punch this
here we go they messed up
shotgun i use it
hey
oh they went a different way yep
any elites or the elites
that's fun to watch oh there you go he's
got a sword he's got a sword oh like i'm
wearing the head um
actually sword shotgun not a good idea i
will be screwed if anything now outside
10 feet of me too much
short that's some
decent
short medium range
there's a little bit of range on it i
want to look around
yeah there's like another passageway did
they come through there we came to the
left they came through there there's
something over here
where i am yeah there's nothing over
here they're not forgetting opening
though guys stop following me around
um
how does that look it looks good right
uh-oh surrendering arjun is not enough
oh no neither
i didn't do that
ship explodes destroying any ships
nearby the reactor is below the last
guns here check those out air ducts
assault rifle
battle rifle
i'll do the battle off but we gotta show
something you know we gotta show it off
sorry full throw with that
whoa that was loud watch this
all right there's another we're going to
try out what are we doing
oh this part's cool
oh so
you guys didn't know hunters are made up
of worms
yeah they're like
they really like
kind of show that off in this game which
is great because
it's so cool
they like assemble and become the hunter
they're gross
let's just oh
he wants to come out let's let him out
the last is
punch proof apparently i'm going to get
him to look this way throw the need
so he's look is back to you oh no you're
not there nevermind so yeah
if you're playing single player you
would like to have your ai distract
him
he's almost down the first one
yeah he's close he's look his back is to
you right now
nice okay uh fred's down if you want to
you might help to get him in this sure
i'll give him a little pick me up
where are you at hey bud
distract this dude
you're still active fred
i'm trying to bow out all right
give me a shotgun oh he doesn't see him
oh no he didn't do it yeah
oh oh no dash
who's he shooting at
yeah nice job oh hunter's down
hey watch this stand back questions
get out of here
blue team
get it i've never seen that happen
before right schematic
all right uh what's in here there's
something battle rifle with this
all right so
bottoms up
doing okay no i'll do it
that was so cool
why are they telling me how to do a
spartan charge now we wouldn't have been
able to get here without
shoot
em tell you in the first mission
yeah
in the beginning of this mission maybe
the game just assumes you don't know
anything like just you know
maybe their assessment sometimes
um
okay this room can get if you're going
too fast you die a lot i agree died a
lot or anywhere you got him he's dead
um
shoot that guy quick
little terminal over here
that's not really too much
forces to get to those controls
yeah
someone's shooting us don't they know
we're trying to listen to a terminal
or an intel yeah
that works of course
i'm gonna go right see what's happening
it means i can't i'm never mind there's
not much
cool i didn't really catch what you said
but
yeah
see so there's cool backstories buried
in that stuff like it was just a weird
kind of
it sounds like the intel it sounds like
tapes from like a zombie thing that
happened on the ship it wasn't it was
yeah right so they just i wish
they they tapped into that more i mean
you should never stand next to them to
listen because it kind of ruins the
momentum well that's definitely an issue
an otherwise very frenetic game like in
a good way all right so [ __ ] yeah they
should they should simply just cut out
when someone talks or any kind of
yeah it battles with the actual main
dialogue right
you can review them in the menu you said
um yeah uh you go to oh i'm adding so
that might be worth it because there's
some some well-written stuff for the
most part oh geez those two turrets just
shot me in the face pretty good those
turrets were creeped up on good and half
pretty bad fred ah fred's down
too we're all down
rifle i don't think we've seen much of
that we
oh you're all down ran up this ramp
turns out there were two turrets at the
top so if you could survive for another
17 seconds that'd be great that'd be
great
you just go ahead and not die that'd be
great
you're doing a pretty good job so far
we feel like doing a ground pound
because i know that's not it's a little
risky isn't it look at all you guys
oh he's coming closer yeah come on once
you get out of the fire fight if you can
i'll be back oh come on come on do it do
it i want you to go watch it good good
they know it they can just pick them out
nope yeah no no i should be able to
spawn if you get cover
oh okay so it's like halo one yeah it's
like the oldest one
so just you not the ai right right
ai's on a timer actually no ai as well
fred's back
okay somewhere
where is it where the hell is fred all
right i'm doing it
oh
i didn't expect that to go so well
yeah kelly's up okay sweet
okay those turrets are really pissing me
off and bumming me out
so i'm gonna go around to the left and
go take them out
okay this guy just just
[ __ ]
all right
behind him
oh down
mama need a hand here
frankie's dead
[ __ ]
the assault rifle i might have said this
already is actually kind of lethal as
opposed to the old just oh [ __ ] that
guy's got a sword heads up he just
pulled it out
he pulled it out
yeah
i gotta get out of here
oh beam rifle
uh there's a fuel rod i will go oh no
plasma cannon sorry never mind different
thing entirely
um sword going with the energy sword
good call yeah we don't you don't need
to tell us just do it
all right
don't say stage freeze just um
you said you got a beam rifle right yeah
probably helpful there's some big room
despite how close quarters this map
looks there are some huge areas in here
yeah this is just a really good mission
overall
i tend to prefer the outdoor missions i
think there's more variety but they'll
do a pretty good job of
switching it up in this game
containment
station's going to try to cool the
reactor
i guess the unsc is better reactor
safety protocol than the covenant
take these coordinates
just go there trust me
oh i want to do my catchphrase
this whole plan fails
or you could say it the game just
doesn't want to hear it
move your feet
oh yeah
i could do this see if my fist goes in
there
such a cool ass move
there are sheds located on either side
of the cooling chamber those are our
targets i love the charge up wait do it
one more time the control shifts kind of
like a trinity thing when she jumps in
the air
all right um look alive
i'm gonna go whoops this way oh i got a
shotgun
bad choice
oh that ground's gotta not everybody's
dead
what am i doing what am i doing dad what
am i doing down
no
i need a hand
oh you and kelly we'll be right there
kelly
nope nope okay
you're good what
why wouldn't it revive uh maybe i was
trying to get kelly on accident my bad
i'll get back to the middle and
it's cool i'll just get some sick shots
[ __ ]
so cool this is so sick
oh jeez this banshee
you know what i'm going to try to do
awesome what are you going to try again
uh he's not coming close enough i want
to just jump off and hijack it come on
you know you want to do it you know you
want to do it yes i dare you to do it
i'm going to i'm going to do it if you
would respond i dare oh i'm back there
you go hope you don't do it i'm going to
do it i'm going to do it here we go
i don't think i'm there i'm gonna dash
and nope
because if i dash in the air i'll give
me a few extra feet that i need another
guy oh hey just you
yes
dude oh my god i landed down here i'm
alive pipes
i thought i died
there's another level down here that i
did not know about sweet that was
helpful
not dying was great
um
okay let's uh just make a break for
those branches because we're not doing
much here
are you down there too
yeah i fell oh i'm gonna go grab these
banshees if we're not yeah here we go
kill that dude oh i'm almost out of ammo
i got a sword though
and this
oh kelly came down too yeah come on
oh what's this here fuel rod cannon
he's dead
all right let's go uh
oh oh wait actually there's a rocket
launch in here i'm gonna
use these fast
pull up a few bonches before we get into
what we're doing
i'm playing like a dumbass
oh that's a fan thanks here we go
yeah oh fred yeah dad the first one oh
he didn't dodge either we got him
all right so the rocket launcher looks
really cool in this game
yeah they completely redid that one um
all right i got one of the banshees
here's another one
he's doing i don't know so i'm gonna
launch a couple at
should
him
should get him at least once
both all right nice
nice job rocky hey josh watch me
go for it
oh you're only completely opposite side
of me okay
there should be rockets in there too
so the vents are open you gotta feel
right in
we're good activate it's uh let's get a
banshee maybe do some
do some damage oh i got a rock launcher
too i'll take it yeah that's helpful
so see these vents you gotta destroy
kind of while we're
not dying it's always good
you got some uh bam yeah
what a little dodge he's dead
the banshees still feel great i mean as
long as you don't
oh
yeah all right
see ya all right back back
what
ah
oh that one's done
that's why it's on fire
i did this dude
i hope you like fuel to the skies
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] if anybody uh caused
some pistols me
suck
it's kind of six
nice i can't shake that oh whoa oh no
that's right you can fall in the sky
that's right
yeah
oh did that just happen to you yeah yeah
it's always you feel badass that when
you pull up at the last second yeah it's
actually really fun um
kill this
then i'll go for it
right next oh i missed i missed oh no
those i did not think those
home dim but that's
a welcome
feature
gotcha all right one more event we're
good
oh and i'm right next to it please
doesn't hurt me
we're good
going over to the hangar bay down here
yeah what else we got here oh there's
one more event sorry
that should be the last one dude i
didn't get a single vent oh here it is
let me get one reactor
i think i got it
fast enough to get clear of the reactor
explosion what so we gotta get to a uh
prowler
oh geez someone's got a fuel rod
fredrick
we're taking a problem oh i'm gonna
splatter this dude
oh my god i missed now he's gonna
let's get out of there
got him
all right let's go there there's the
hanger entrance just like anakin
skywalker and phantom manus
classic reference
are we all here okay
actually when they get when when the ai
gets out uh
get out
what is this
i don't know actually that was that was
pretty that was pretty smooth okay uh
you definitely heard me sorry already
off it
where's kelly
yeah so she's oh she's right here no
fred just got into a banshee again in
the hangar bed temperature
oh uh doris what is he doing
all right mostly fred to do his thing
i think this is the last are there three
of these
eight wow
around
there's some us
weapons over here ooh i saw do you want
it want me to take it uh okay i'm gonna
keep the rocket launcher in case there
are you know tough rail guns nice
i don't know i don't like the railgun at
all
i don't like i mean it's charging it's
like a spartan laser i was never great
with it spartan a laser at least was
extremely strong and which made it a lot
of fun the rail gun doesn't do much it's
just like i don't know
it's a one-hit kill on elites but it
is it do you want to uh mark this fuel
rod cannon so one of them picks it up
sure
i can't oh tell them okay wait wait
that's right so you can tell you're the
ai to do this so and they're actually
pretty good with power weapons so kelly
will pick that up hopefully give her a
pistol another shot yeah yeah
so and then to
uh command the second guy i i double tap
it right
i think so yeah if you do it in within
enough time of the first tab it'll be
the second one are there any other cool
weapons we can try on oh [ __ ] i just
dropped it way down i think i have i'm
gonna go low get that
out of here
see what happened what goes on down here
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] happens in the
sewers control panel all right
here let's see if you're right
uh-oh hey god oh god oh
my nice
all right let's see this
pick up this weapon
so he's getting it uh you told him to
get the height take your time take your
time dude we're fine
there's a oh what's going on there's a
hydrological
bread just dashed out of the way so okay
do they not maybe i wonder if they don't
equip swords
maybe there is a hydrologic on the next
like in this we could take i mean
actually i might take this do you uh no
i have a rocket launcher listen to me
yes
get the [ __ ] weapon over here if you
press it 10 times he just gets really
pissed
all right fine he doesn't want it he
just he turned his back to me this is
unacceptable all right then you want
this weapon got it um should i power up
the prowler
see this is really i
okay you take this
and he takes that fuel cells
okay great no you take this
for launch
now
sure
there we go there we go all right dream
team a lot of dudes come in
elite
anything cool around here did i press
that
what i pressed that button
hunters
oh he's right next to you he's right
next to
hunter
the rockets don't travel as fast in this
game the rack is
did i say it like christopher walker no
you didn't i wanted you to know
oh my god i'm so sorry what uh yeah oh
that was you no kelly shot a rocket at
you uh-huh
oh they're getting you i'll cover them
kelly doesn't have a rocket launcher
mike
oh [ __ ] this this dude okay that's that
was hold off on shooting kelly did that
whoa oh
he is why is he glowing green he's
almost dead because he's hot
he's gone he's just a hot dude there's
one with the sword next to you hold on
yeah i got you
yeah
yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't don't damn it i'm stuck
on this crate there's one behind me
that's right
we're all dead
damn it there's this little air tank
behind me that was preventing me from
backing up
if it wasn't there
all right it's on try that again so i
want you to rocky this time i kind of
can make up for that he's right next to
you guys still though kelly what are you
doing kelly
oh god kelly's down she deserved it
oh
so did i hunt down
uh fred when you we're all down holy
[ __ ]
right that's my team
all right
i want that elite where is he at where's
my where's my boy at i wanna
fight him
yeah
yeah
all right i'll come save you he's not
going so good i'm i'm dead but i'll be
back in 12 seconds
ooh that grenade worked three seconds
assuming nothing goes so wait three
seconds and you're
okay wait safe area yeah now it's just
back to the classic halo get to a safe
spot we're relatively out of a fire
fight
there we go i'm back oh i got my sniper
rifle too dude that wasn't safe that's a
little cheap yeah i do have my sniper
rifle though
i don't want to waste i'll i don't care
i'll shoot him i'll shoot this ground
right here oh never mind what's that too
all right let's
cut let's rail gun him in the face
let me know if you see that elite with
this old rocket launcher hi how are ya
whoa
all right 100's down
grenade this one i'm gonna okay i've got
a sniper i'm gonna shoot him right in
the
back
come on turn around
oh [ __ ]
kelly oh he's looking right at me
kelly's shooting report kelly you were
just oh you're give me a hand oh look at
it they have to go all the way around
thanks brad
oh
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i got some plasma
casters what i got
the hunter's still a lot yeah all right
i think they're both why is he keep
looking at me can you guys shoot him
because he's really annoying to me how
much he's looking right at me i have a
sniper
all right you know i'm gonna shoot this
guy oh [ __ ]
all right
oh watch this
all right
dad
oh
oh [ __ ] this is so dumb
get out of there
i'm being very cautious
i'm just going for it
i'm going to spark smash him
and then i'm going to do one of these on
this dude
he's dead
he went flying
sounds like that's it
yeah
blue team oh there's a rocket launcher
right in the center that i had no idea
what's there
wait wait launch it at me i wanna i'm
out
get this one out get this one over here
i'm gonna dash i'm gonna sidestep it he
does this in the first book
you know a jet shoots a missile enemy
sidesteps and slaps it away oh i wanna
test out my team first
wait
take this position
oh [ __ ] damn it
yeah don't chief is really losing it in
this game you know
fred's there
what
fred don't you ever give me your back
oh kelly
oh wait hold on oh damn it you launched
me into the
i want to dash away from a rocket they
travel pretty slowly in this game 89
seconds
89 seconds
89 seconds specific
unless you're talking about a bomb go
okay
it's like you know kelly just say 90.
come on
don't be that person
i don't like it whoever they are let's
get to meridian before they do kelly no
no need to do this by yourself what
accent is kelly's
she british
yeah she's so british
won't court-martial all of us right
that'd be really funny if they got back
like yeah we're going to court-martial
all four of you
oh yeah i met a person named court
marshall before
that was court martial
no his name was court marshall
what i i'm i'm kidding but that'd be a
crazy name
marshall marshall marshall court
yeah
thea
chief
out cool
great
well
are we doing mission three or um calling
it
i don't
know if we are
continuing
uh
i can get
maybe a
heads up
or
you know
i mean i don't care but probably
is uh is tay unfortunately not able to
join us
nope okay okay
um yeah why don't we stop here cool
it works for me i try to warn you this
what's happening plus this this mission
kind of ends
up
captain cheese that way doesn't matter
sure oh never will
cool
that was
halo 5 co-op two-player you can do
four-player fortunately we cannot do
that today we will be doing that at
another point i'm sure of it definitely
next week
um
multiplayer started today but
unfortunately there's not a whole lot of
people playing so you can count on
tomorrow we have some dedicated servers
going up
starting tomorrow all the way through
the
monday
of next week
and
there tomorrow you will see some warzone
and some other multiplayer
and
we will have something up monday in
terms of uh review-ish right but we're
gonna you know make sure servers are
working and everything so definitely get
some thoughts from uh our reviewer
i'll be reviewing this party i am in the
process yeah we'll have something on
monday and then absolutely
hopefully yeah we'll have a lot of
content a lot of multiplayer content i'm
sure
um
going up monday
and then we can probably expect the
review maybe tuesday
we're hoping so yeah hoping so cool well
that was the stream hope you guys
enjoyed
and stay tuned
to tomorrow for war zone take care now
you